I feel so strongly that the reason I'm
here is I dreamed big dreams I dreamed
the kind of dreams that other people
said would not be possible I'm also
living proof this isn't a Hollywood
movie I counted literally from the other
side of the tracks if you saw where I
grew up
and we took a picture of it the
neighborhood the setting you say it's
not it's impossible that someone could
come from there
and get here but it is possible and not
to sound too trite it's possible because
we still live in a country with the
entrepreneurial spirit it's so alive and
so well and anyone in this country if
you dream big and surround yourself with
great people and leave your ego at the
door and share a success with others and
have a little luck along the way you can
do anything but there will be people
along the way and I remember this who
will say to you you know you're dreaming
too big it's not possible those things
just can't happen don't allow anyone
friend family acquaintances teachers
whoever it is don't allow anyone to tell
you that what you are dreaming for
yourself and your family is not possible
it is possible don't be one of those
people 20 years from now are going to be
walking around a nine-to-five job
miserable and angry and bitter because
you let your dreams get away from you
because you did not believe stronger
enough strongly enough in yourself and
what was possible don't allow that to
happen this is an unbelievable time and
I can't encourage you enough to continue
to think that things are possible and
that your dreams can come true